this epic trench battle from 1917
was shot to look like one long take and
it was a huge
challenge for both the cast and crew it
involved multiple cranes
speeding trucks and perfectly timed
handoffs
but this is just one example of a
one-take scene or a oner
that pushed filmmakers to their limits
and required
impressive technical innovations here's
how eight movie and tv scenes were shot
to look like one long tape
one take scenes are naturally suited for
intense action
as you can see in this fight scene in
atomic blonde
despite shooting in a real building the
crew still had to alter the set to
accommodate the wanter
for example they built this elevator
which helped create a natural stitch
point
a way to hide the moment the camera cuts
and keep the continuous illusion going
they also use another stitching
technique called body crossing
in which a cut is hidden when a
performer blocks the camera as seen here
with this henchman
because the fight was shot to look like
one take it needed to be shot in
chronological order
so the effects team had to constantly
apply new makeup to charlize theron and
the other characters as the fighting
continued and
injuries increased charlize did her own
stunts for a large part of this sequence
however for some of the riskier moves
the crew subbed in her stunt devil
monique ganderton
for example the director used motion
blur when charlize had to fall down the
stairs and slam into a wall
that's actually monique tumbling down
the stairs before switching back to
charlize hitting the wall
unlike atomic blonde netflix's
extraction hops from location to
location
as opposed to just one building the
entire sequence goes on for about 12
minutes and consists of approximately 36
segments cobbled together
the non-stop action required director
sam hargrave to do some stunts of his
own
for this car chase he strapped himself
to the hood of another vehicle
and then had to quickly unstrap himself
and place the camera inside the other
car
he then had to replicate the same shot
backwards by leaning out the car once he
was inside
this helped create a natural transition
point if sam's position was off even
slightly
they'd have to shoot it all over again
then for this shot where chris hemsworth
stunt double tumbles off an awning
sam roped himself into a pulley system
to get up close to the action
the sequence also fools the eye in many
other ways for instance when ovi runs
through this doorway he is actually
running into a room in a different
building 10 blocks away
the crew had to change locations to one
where there was more space to pull off
the upcoming action
and like with atomic blonde they
frequently swapped out chris with his
stunt double
bobby hall and hanton the first shot you
see here is
chris's face they could then pan to his
double without anyone noticing by
shooting the back of his head
for the day of the dead parade scene
inspector cinematographer hoytavon
hoitima
wanted to start big and then go small
and intimate
that meant starting wide with parade
shots then getting in closer to the
marchers before following bond into a
hotel room
to pull this off hoyte used a
technocrane the crane started high and
then lowered down into the crowd without
cutting
a steadicam operator then jumped off
pushed farther into the crowd
and followed actor daniel craig up to
the hotel room
while the street scenes were shot in
mexico the hotel room was actually
set in the uk the crowd scenes featured
1500 extras according to ilm vfx
supervisor mark bukowski
since they couldn't get a perfect shot
where every extra looked the right way
at the right time the vfx team inserted
digital
masks over their faces
sometimes runners are limited by the
space they're shot in
which means the crew needs to be a bit
more creative
in the season 2 premiere of the
marvelous mrs maisel
cinematographer m david mullen had to
lead the camera through a fictional
department store
through a mail slot and then into the
small room where midge mazel works as a
switchboard operator
unlike other continuous shots there were
no wide spaces for the camera to pass
through
just five feet of space between these
two rows of actresses
for both camera person and performer it
was about precise
timing the space was so tight that the
actresses had to lean back so they
wouldn't get hit by the camera
then when the camera went through the
center of the room actresses wheeled
around in their chairs so they wouldn't
block the shot
for birdman it wasn't just one scene but
the entire movie that needed to look
like one long take
according to director alejandro gonzalez
and yarito
some of the takes were up to 20 minutes
long because of the amount of movement
in the film
birdman was shot using small handheld
cameras and steadicams
these allowed the crew to more easily
follow the cast as they walked through
new york's crowded streets
this also meant the crew couldn't use
typical large light kits
so according to cinematographer emmanuel
lubezki
they instead relied on natural and
practical lights in the scene
like these colorful light bulbs above
michael keaton and even the lights
emitting from times square
birdman wasn't just a challenge for the
crew it was also a huge endeavor for the
cast
according to emma stone if she flubbed
even a single word
she'd have to start again from the very
top
like birdman 1917 was also filmed to
look like
one single take over its entire two-hour
running time
but it was even more complicated due to
its epic battle sequences
pulling this film off involved the most
careful planning imaginable
every set was precisely measured out and
could be no longer than the length the
camera could travel
since the crew was constantly on foot
they relied almost entirely on natural
light
look at the scene where scofield runs
through a destroyed city
it was lit up by flares in the sky
because the flares were the main light
for part of the scene
the crew needed to time exactly how long
the flares needed to be in the air
they figured this out in pre-production
where they ran a light above a mini
model of the set
to see where exactly all the shadows
would fall of course the film also
relied on stitch points
like here when blake and scofield walk
through a black curtain
but most of its magic was accomplished
using innovations in technology
for example schofield's journey down
river was captured by a drone
meanwhile lighter and smaller cameras
allowed the crew to move through
trenches and difficult terrain with ease
then to get across no man's land
cinematographer roger deakins and the
crew attached cameras to a cable system
above the set
this shot where scofield runs through a
destroyed city and jumps off a ledge and
into a river
was too dangerous to do in real life so
the part of him running was shot on set
while the jump was actually shot using
cgi with a swap background that allowed
for a seamless transition
shooting continuous takes means it's
hard to call cut so it's not ideal for
making mistakes
but this moment here where actor george
makai runs alongside the trench and then
trips
was not intentional but in the end it
felt natural
so it stayed in the movie
the entire set for this episode of the
haunting of hill house had to be built
specifically to accommodate a single
shot
take a look at this elevator it was
designed to lower the camera person
down to the next floor and allow them to
capture the shot of olivia and hugh
running down the stairs without a break
because the camera goes between hill
house and the funeral home in the
episode
the two stages were actually built
adjacent to each other and connected by
a hallway
this allowed the camera to follow hugh
as he walked directly from the funeral
home
into the house runners are frantic by
nature
and they involve a lot of movement and
setup changes the hill house set
had places throughout for the crew and
their equipment to hide whenever the
camera turned in their direction
like with birdman and 1917 hill house
also demonstrated the challenges of
lighting a warner
if an actor missed a cue they wouldn't
be lit properly so
series creator mike flanagan came up
with a unique solution
when he clapped these two wood blocks
together the cast member knew what to do
one take scenes aren't just used to show
movement from place to place
they can also be really useful in
showing the passage of time
this scene from the showtime series
kidding shows the character
shayna watching mr pickles puppet time
on her tv
as her life progresses and improves
around her
the shot captures five years of her life
over the course of one minute and 42
seconds
because the camera had to circle
constantly around the room as it changed
this endeavor was an absolute mad rush
for the cast and crew
to show the passage of time the camera
operator circled around the room
each area of the room would show a new
development in shaina's life
so whenever the camera wasn't focused on
them the 50 crew members had to swap out
furniture and bring in new props
then this wall slid over into the
kitchen while that was happening actress
ricky lindholm had to go through
multiple costume changes
some of which involved using a body
double
what are some of your favorite one take
scenes let us know in the comments
[Music]